nous avons reçu de nouvelles images je
ne les ai pas encore vus nous allons les
découvrir ensemble je vous rappelle
quand même les principales consignes de
sécurité et elles sont nombreuses les
services de secours demande à la
population toulousaine et à la banlieue
de rester chez elles dans un endroit
confiné de libérer bien évidemment les
axes de circulation pour permettre aux
services de secours de la vie mais aussi
des départements voisins de venir faire
leur travail sur les lieux de la
catastrophe
libéré aussi si possible les lignes
téléphoniques parce que le réseau est
saturé c'est très difficile pour les
services de ce furent deux de faire leur
travail
il faut savoir aussi qu'il est qu'il est
bien d'éviter de consommer l'eau potable
non pas parce qu'il ya un danger mais
parce qu'il ya une usine qui alimente
les conduites qui aurait été touché et
c'est tout simplement pour éviter une
pénurie
je vous propose maintenant d'écouter de
nouveaux témoignages qui ont été repris
ce matin par nicole knowles excusez moi
mais justement des salades et sept
blessés je ne parle pas des tic où
j'étais au travail et vous monsieur
excusez-moi j'ai lavé mois une forêt de
lingots commence à s'écrouler le coche
mais on est sortis plus vite possible
mais c'est bon j'ai eu mon premier
enfant que je que j'ai ri c'est vrai on
était dans un atelier et ça explose et
on n'a rien vu mais je n'ai pas de
stratégie non non non parce que c'est
plus vers la grande tour verte qui avait
requis à l'époque et plus d'ailleurs
allez tomber la brique quoi la veille 6e
mon nitrates agricoles
partout
est ce que tu peux vous dire qu'il
voulait construire
désolé de sa mine et ont essayé après
d'aller voir allure et pascal sûrs et on
sait pas du tout ce qui se passe vous
êtes le directeur
je suis directeur adjoint on a eu une
explosion
on sait tous se retrouvaient dans l'état
où on est là je ne peux pas vous en dire
plus pour l'instant
donc notre première priorité c'est de
d'évacuer les blessés et j'ai fait
évacué à l'hôpital marchant qui est à
côté
la plupart des gens valides parce que
nous avons potentiellement un problème
de gaz de fuite de gaz dans l'usiné il
ya beaucoup de blessés
pour l'instant je pense qu'il y ait au
moins une dizaine de blessés
il y en a qui sont dans un état très
grave ah oui je pense mais pour
l'instant je peux vous donner de
diagnostic un ton peu première priorité
c'est isoler les suites potentielles de
gaz évacuer les blessés
et après on essaiera de comprendre d'où
ça vient